droht eine große pandemie eine weltweite
epidemie zwischen 11.15 juni will den
lippen schürzen neue fälle von merz
aufgetreten das 2012 zum ersten mal
entdeckte virus hat eine extrem hohe
mortalitätsrate das heißt es ist tödlich
35 prozent der identifizierten
infizierten starben bisher
das ist extrem hoch doch es gibt ein
licht liegt wahrscheinlich gibt es
bereits wenn eine pandemie beginnen
sollte ein wirkungsvolles medikament
jetzt geht es darum daran mit hochdruck
befassen
bis zum 26 taxi willkommen
seit jahren fürchten epidemiologen und
mediziner eine große familie immer
wieder treten erreger auf die sich
rasant verbreiten
beispiele sind schweinegrippe die
vogelgrippe ebola sars oder auch merz
und letzterer erreger ist im moment ein
sehr aktiver kandidat die gefahr einer
pandemie steigt bei der mensch auch
durch den klimawandel bedingt ihn immer
weiter unbekannte regionen vordringen
und dort mit tieren in kontakt kommt zu
denen er vorher keinen kontakt hatte bei
ebola waren es zum beispiel flughunde
wie in der region gegessen wurden und so
den virus verbreitet nur der mensch hat
dann keinerlei antikörper um sich gegen
das virus zu wehren und wenn wie beim r
viele infizierte sterben ist die gefahr
einer verheerenden pandemie tatsächlich
groß dabei gehört das virus zu dem bkh
coronaviren erkältungsviren die schnell
auf neue wirte überspringen und
schwerere krankheitsverläufe verursachen
können
das heißt dann über atemprobleme
lungenentzündung durchfall und
nierenversagen und bisher gibt es gegen
diese wären keine therapie und keine
vorbeugende impfung die menschheit die
keinerlei antikörper gegen den erreger
hat wäre einer märz pandemie schutzlos
ausgeliefert doch jetzt gibt es einen
lichtblick eine substanz die bereits
gegen ebola eingesetzt wurde und damals
in einem schnellverfahren klinisch
getestet wurde wie scheint auch gegen
korona viren wie sars oder märz zu
wirken zuerst mal wäre damit ein mittel
gegen eine derartige pandemie gefunden
allerdings gibt es ein paar unangenehme
nachteile aber der reihe nach
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
um die moscheen von der university
moskau rainer fanden heraus dass der
wirkstoff bf 5734 viren wie mars und saß
blockieren kann mäuse wie einen tag vor
oder einen tag nach einer infektion mit
dem wirkstoff behandelt wurden hatten
deutlich weniger gewichtsverlust und
atemwegsbeschwerden allerdings und jetzt
kommt der haken wurde der wirkstoff
einige tage später verabreicht nutzte er
nichts mehr
zwar wurden die viren verringert doch
die symptome gingen nicht zurück und
auch in menschlichen lungengewebe und
wieder eine gute nachricht wurde der
wirkstoff von getestete festgestellt
dass er das gewebe nicht die
nebenwirkung dürften also gering sein
vorteil des wirkstoffes
er greift nicht die hoch variablen
rezeptoren auf der höhe des erregers an
sondern greift in den vervielfältigung
mechanismus ein das macht ihn besonders
interessant für einen sicheren und
effektiven einsatz um schwere verläufe
bei einer infektion zu verhindern zwar
kann eine bande niveau nicht verhindert
werden aber der wirkstoff könnte zur
vorsorge verteilt werden die pandemie
würde zwar stattfinden aber die wäre
weitaus weniger tödlich denn zu
verhindern ist sie laut experten und
expertinnen nicht mehr fängt so harmlos
an dass der virus sich schnell
verbreitet hätte und erst dann zu den
tödlichen folgen führen würde dann
müsste schnell reagiert werden und der
wirkstoff verteilt werden allerdings
wird zurzeit auch noch an impfungen
gearbeitet um die verbreitung zu
verhindern
gelingt das allerdings nicht schnell
genug ist eine pandemie kaum aufzuhalten
wie die entwicklung so weitergeht
erfahrt ihr natürlich hier wenn ihr kein
video zu dem thema verpassen wollten
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke und
hier geht es weiter mit masern epidemie
durch impfgegner hervorrufen wenn es
euch interessiert einfach draufklicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt